is there a connection is there a
correlation between
the mental health of a human mind and
the division
of our political discipline oh yes oh
yes
so our brains are structured to be
uh really good at approach and avoid so
we have circuits the front left circle
isn't over simplification but there's
some truth to it there's what's called
the behavioral activation system front
left cortex it's all about approach
opportunity you know kid in a candy
store and then the front right cortex
has circuits specialized for withdrawal
fear threat and of course students you
know i'm a college professor and most of
us think about our college days like you
know yeah we were anxious at times but
it was fun and it was like i can take
all these courses i can do all these
clubs all these people
now imagine if in 2013 all of a sudden
students are coming in with their front
right cortex hyperactivated everything's
a threat
everything is dangerous there's not
enough to go around
so
the front right cortex puts us into
what's called defend mode as opposed to
discover mode now let's move up to
adults imagine
a large diverse secular liberal
democracy in which people are most of
the time in discover mode
and you know we have a problem let's
think how to solve it and this is what
de tocqueville said about americans like
there's a problem we get together we
figure out how to solve it and he said
whereas in england and france people
would wait for the king to do it but
here like let the you know the role
person do it that's the can do mindset
that's front left cortex discover mode
if you have a national shift of people
spending more time in defend mode now
you so everything that comes up whatever
anyone says you're not looking like oh
is there something good about you
thinking you know how is this dangerous
how is this a threat how is this
violence how can i attack this how can i
you know so so if you imagine you know
god up there with a little lever like
okay let's let's push everyone over into
you know more into discover mode and
it's like joy breaks out age of aquarius
all right let's shift them back into
let's put everyone in defend mode and i
can't think of a better way to put
people in defend mode than to have them
spend some time on um partisan or
political twitter where it's just a
stream of horror stories including
videos about how horrible the other side
is and it's not just that they're bad
people it's that if they win this
election
then we lose our country or then it's
catastrophe
so twitter and again we're not saying
all of twitter
you know
most people aren't on twitter and people
that are mostly not talking about
politics but the ones that are on
talking about politics are flooding us
with stuff
all the journalists see it all
mainstream media is hugely influenced by
twitter um so if we put everyone if
there's more sort of anxiety sense of
threat this colors everything and then
you're not you know the great thing
about about a democracy and especially a
you know or a legislature that has some
diversity in it is that the art of
politics is that you can grow the pie
and then divide it you don't just fight
zero sum you you find ways that we can
all get sixty percent of what we want
uh and that that ends when everyone's
anxious and angry so
let's try to start to figure out who's
to blame here
is it the nature of social media is it
the decision
of of
the people at the heads of social media
companies that they're making in the
detailed engineering designs of the
algorithm
is it the users of social media that
drive narratives like you mentioned
journalists
that want to maximize drama in order to
uh
drive clicks to their off-site
articles
is it just human nature
that loves drama can't look away from an
accident when you're driving by is there
is there something to be said about the
reason that i ask these questions is to
see can we start to figure out what the
solution would be
uh for to to uh to alleviate to
de-escalate not yet not yet let's first
we have to understand
um you know as as we did on the teen
mental health thing okay now let's lay
out what is the problem what's messing
up our country and then we'll we can
talk about solutions so it's all the
things you said interacting in an
interesting way um so human nature is
tribal we evolve for intergroup conflict
um we love war um we uh the first time
my buddies and i played paintball i was
29 um and we were divided into teams
with strangers to shoot guns at each
other and kill each other and we all
afterwards it was like oh my god that
was incredible like it really felt like
we'd opened a room in our hearts that
had never been opened but as men you
know testosterone changes our brains and
our bodies and activates the war stuff
like we've got more stuff and that's why
boys like certain team sports it's play
war
so that's who we are um it doesn't mean
we're always tribal it doesn't mean
we're always wanting to fight we're also
really good at making peace and
cooperation and finding deals we're good
at trade and exchange so you know
you want your country to you want a
society that has room for conflict
ideally over sports like that's great
that's totally it's not just harmless
it's actually good um but otherwise you
want cooperation to generally prevail in
the society that's how you create
prosperity and peace
and if you're gonna have a diverse
democracy you really better focus on
cooperation not on tribalism and
division
and there's a wonderful book by yasha
monk called the great experiment that
talks about the difficulty of diversity
in democracy and and and what we need to
do to
get this right and to get the benefits
of diversity
so that's human nature
now let's imagine that the technological
environment makes it really easy for us
to cooperate let's give everyone
telephones and the postal service let's
give them email like wow you know we can
do all these things together with people
far away it's amazing
now instead of that let's give them a
technology that encourages them to fight
so
early facebook and twitter were
generally lovely places um you know
people old enough to remember like they
were fun there's a lot of humor um you
didn't feel like you're gonna get your
head blown off no matter what you said
um
2007 2008 2009 it was still fun these
were nice places mostly and like almost
all the platforms started off as nice
places
um but and this is
the key thing in the in the article in
the atlantic article
on babel on after babel the atlantic
article by the way is why the past 10
years of american life have been
uniquely stupid
yeah my title in the magazine was after
babel uh adapting to a world we can no
longer share that's what i propose but
they they a b tested what's the title it
gets the most clicks and it was why the
past 10 years have been used the bible
the tower of babel is a um
is a driving metaphor in the piece so
what
first of all what is it what's the tower
of babel what's what's babel what are we
talking about so the tower of babel is a
story in early in genesis where the
descendants of noah are spreading out
and repopulating the world and they're
on the plane of shinar and they say let
us build us a city with a tower to make
a name for ourselves lest we be
scattered again and so it's a very short
story there's not a lot in it but it
looks like they're saying you know we
don't want god to flood us again let's
build a city in a tower
and to reach the heavens and god is
offended by the hubris of these people
um acting again like gods
and he says here's the key line he says
let us go down and confuse their
language so that they may not understand
one another
so in the story he doesn't literally
knock the tower over but you know many
of us have seen images or you know movie
drama dramatizations where a great wind
comes and the tower is knocked over and
the people are left wandering amid the
rubble unable to talk to each other
so i've been grappling i've been trying
to say what the hell happened to our
society
you know beginning in 2014 what the hell
is happening to universities and then it
spread out from universities it hit
journalism the arts and now it's all
over companies
um what the hell happened to us and it
wasn't until i reread the babel story a
couple of years ago that i thought whoa
this is it this is the metaphor because
you know i've been thinking about
tribalism and left right battles and war
and
that's easy to think about but babel
isn't like you know and god said let
half of the people hate the other half
no it wasn't that it's god said let us
confuse their language that they none of
them can understand each other ever
again or at least for a while
um so it's a story about fragmentation
and that's what's unique about our time
so
so meta or facebook wrote a rebuttal um
to my article they disputed what i said
uh and one of their arguments was oh but
you know
polarization goes back way before social
media
and you know and it um it was happening
in the 90s and they're right it does and
i should i i did say that but i should
have said it more clearly with more
examples but here's the new thing
even though left and right we're
beginning to hate each other more
we weren't afraid of the person next to
us we weren't afraid of each other cable
tv
you know fox news whatever you want to
point to about increasing polarization
it didn't make me afraid of my students
and that was new in around 2014 2015. we
started hearing getting articles
you know i'm a liberal professor and my
liberal students frightened me it was in
vox in 2015. and that was after greg and
i had turned in the draft of our uh of
our first draft of our coddling article
and surveys show over and over again
students are not as afraid of their
professors they're actually afraid of
other students
most students are lovely it's not like
the whole generation has lost their
minds
what happens is small number
a small number are adept at using social
media to destroy anyone that they think
they can get credit for destroying
and the bizarre thing is it's never it's
rarely about what ideas you express it's
usually about a word like he used this
word
or this you know this was insensitive or
you know i can link this word to that
so it's it's a it's they don't really
engage with ideas and arguments it's a
real sort of gotcha um prosecutor almost
you know it's like a like a witch trial
mindset um
so so the unique thing here there's
something about social media in those
years
that a small number of people
can sort of be catalysts for this
division they can start the viral wave
that leads to a division that's
different than the kind of division we
saw before it's a little different than
viral wave once you get some people who
can who can use social media to
intimidate you get a you get a sudden
phase shift you get a big change in the
dynamics of groups and that's the heart
of the article this isn't just another
article about how social media is
polarizing us and destroying democracy
the heart of the article
is an analysis of what makes groups
smart and what makes them stupid
and so
because as we said earlier you know my
own research is on post-hoc reasoning
just post-hoc justification
rationalization the only cure for that
is other people who don't share your
biases and so if you have an academic
debate as like the one i'm having with
you know with these other researchers
over social media you know i write
something they write something i have to
take account of their arguments and they
have to take account of mine when the
academic world works it's because it
puts us together in ways that things
cancel out that's what makes
universities smart what makes them
generators of knowledge
unless we stop dissent
what if we say
on these topics there can be no dissent
and if anyone says otherwise if any
academic comes up with research that
says otherwise we're going to destroy
them and if any academic even tweets a
study
contradicting what is the official word
we're going to destroy them and that was
the famous case of david shore who in
the days after george floyd was killed
and there were protests and the question
is are these protests going to be
productive are they going to backfire
now most of them were peaceful but some
were violent and he tweeted a study he
just simply tweeted a study uh done by
an action african-american i think
sociologist at princeton
omar wassau
and wasa's study showed that when you
look back at the 60s you see that where
there were violent protests it tended to
backfire peaceful protests tend to work
and so he simply tweeted that study
and there was a twitter mob after him
this was insensitive this was uh
anti-black i think he was accused of and
he was fired within a day or two
so this is the kind of dynamic this is
not caused by cable tv this is not cause
this is something new can i uh just on a
small tangent there
uh in that situation because it happens
time and time again you highlight in
your current work but also in the
calling of the american mind
is the blame on the mob the mechanisms
that enables the mob or the people that
do the firing the administration does
the firing yeah it's all of them well
can i i sometimes feel
that we don't put enough blame on the
people that do the firing
which is that feels like
in the long arc of human history that is
the place for courage and for ideals
right that's where it stops that's where
the buck stops like
is so if there's going to be new
mechanisms for mobs and all that kind of
stuff there's going to be tribalism yeah
but at the end of the day that's what it
means to be a leader is to stop
stop the mob at the door but i'm a
social psychologist which means i look
at the social forces at work on people
yes and if and if you show me a
situation in which 95 of the people
behave one way and it's a way that we
find surprising and shameful
i'm not going to say wow 95 of the
people are shameful i'm going to say wow
what a powerful situation
we've got to change that situation
so that's what i think is happening here
because there are hardly any in the
first few years you know it began around
2018 2019 it really enters the corporate
world and there are hardly any leaders
who stood up against it uh but i've
talked to a lot and it's it's always the
same thing
you have these you know you know people
in their usually their 50s or 60s
generally they're progressive or on the
left
they're accused of things by their young
employees
they don't have the vocabulary to stand
up to it
and they give in very quickly
and because it happens over and over
again and there's only a few examples of
university presidents who said like no
we're not going to stop this talk just
because you're freaking out no you know
we're not going to fire this professor
because he wrote a paper that you that
you you don't like
you